good attitude everybody welcome to the
roundtable within the series of the
global governance today we are going to
discuss a very challenging issue
migration is a global challenge
well since earliest times humanity has
been on the move some people move in
search of new economic opportunities and
horizons others move to escape armed
conflicts poverty food insecurity
persecution terrorism or human rights
violations and abuses still others do so
in response to the adverse effects of
climate change natural disasters some of
which may be linked to climate change or
other environmental factors many move
indeed for a combination of these
reasons we are witnessing in today's
world an unprecedented level of human
mobility the number of international
migrants worldwide has continued to grow
over the past 17 years reaching 258
million in 2017 up to 248 million in
2015
today I have a privilege to welcome in
blues hall good friends colleagues and
senior ambassadors from the United
Nations who are going to share with you
on their vision on the problems of
migration this phenomena which bringing
new challenges to the mankind we will
speak today about the about this
phenomena in from his point of view of
divinity of morality of ethics of
politics of the global management and I
would like to start this discussion
inviting to the panel the good friend of
mine and a person who is well known in
the diplomatic community of United
Nations who shared a lot of the
different bodies here
ambassador amar Hillel his country this
year is presiding this summit on Global
Compact the new configuration which is
trying to bring the Morton
a clearance on what is migration is and
to help identify those problems which
have not been identified in
international documents on the refugees
even a declaration your declaration on
migration so this is a very challenging
assignment ambassador a lot of made a
lot of efforts in the United Nations to
bring a harmony and consensus and he is
going to share with you today on his
country vision and his own on the on the
process around the Global Compact and
what the global community expected from
the summit in Morocco ambassadors Larry
you have her flosser is the number one
to be bought in national politics wide
migration has existed throughout human
history this public company grew in
importance during the last three or four
years in fact human have almost be of
the world but in 2011 major events okay
are the doors of Europe the so-called
Arab Spring which led to the fall of
safety belt around Europe this events
were the main three therefore the very
first
sumit to be solely devoted to the large
movement of migrants and refugees which
took place on the margin of the General
Assembly in September currency system
there was consensus that the world needs
Joran action better manage migration the
regional and informal process were not
enough dealing with specific aspect of
migration was not enough the war needed
a global and comprehensive approach for
migration so the New York declaration
which was adopted at that summit
we paired to the ongoing process leading
to the Global Compact for safe orderly
and regular migration JCM to be adopted
in Marrakesh on 10 December 2018 it is a
document the j-3 and his landmark
achievement for migration once adopted
it will be the very first UN document
defining a common approach to Intl
vibration in all its name asha the GCM
is not not legally binding it is
grounded in values or state sovereignty
responsibilities sharing noms
elimination and human rights and
recognize that a cooperative approach is
needed to optimize the overall benefit
of migration while addressing its risk
and challenges for individuals and
communities and countries of origin
transit and destination the
interpolation of this air was not an
easy task it took more than even hard to
reach an agreement of the 31 pages of
systems or the document to
co-facilitators ambassadors of Mexicans
were German let the preparatory process
it comprises three phases first the
consultation phase through a ceiling of
six and former thematic sessions
neighbors vision
consultations as well as stakeholders
consultations help between April and
November 2017 second the stop taking
phase during conference in Puerto
Vallarta Mexico in December 2017 it
assess all inputs received during the
consultation phase it alone shaping the
vision for this era you say
third the negotiation stage which
started on 5th February and finished in
13th July 2018 since Ronald of lengthy
and hard and technical muttered
negotiation permission necessary to
reach an agreement on the drug GCF which
will be adopted in Marrakesh let me now
move to the contents of the desire first
let's answer four basic four four basic
questions about this a first how is the
Global Compact shift and what is in the
GCM begins with preamble and then
guiding projects including national
sovereignty the non-binding character of
the document and the at the National
Road and the commitment to universality
of Human Rights the reason comprised 23
objectives which had one mitigating the
adverse drivers and Schlichter factors
that push people to leave their
countries of origin to reducing the risk
and vulnerable vulnerability migrants
stays at a different stage of migration
through addressing the constant of
states and community for creating
community conducive conditions that
enable all migrants to enrich society
seventh question with the GCM result in
National Civil Rights the umbrella
interest or pretend no the answer is no
upholding national sovereignty is
guiding passive
the GCF come first the solar lights off
and up quoting here the GaN rarely
affects the sovereign right of states to
determine the Machine immigration policy
and their prerogative to govern
migration within the gel addiction in
conformity will have their national
tense of co-ownership para 15c national
sovereignty rights will neither be
created or no spell the gist and will
not be an international agreement and we
therefore have no legal effect or
national legal system third question we
did you say establish a right immigrant
the GCM will not create any new legal
categories it expressly point out that
national sovereignty will be upheld
especially when it comes to resonance
and border issues at the same time the
Jews had explicitly stressed the human
rights of all members this includes
support for migrants and especially
dangerous situation in particular
children in line with valid obligation
under the National rule the fourth
question is what impact will decision
have in regular migration the GCM aims
at making migration orderly and regular
negative Swifter factors in country of
origin which lead to migration should be
minimized that's the objective number
two
smugglers and human trafficking property
was transnationally thus objective nine
and ten and border management better
coordinated regional migration on the
other hand which is necessary in many
parts of the world due to demographic
and in order to meet the needs of the
labour market should be facilitated at
this stage I would like to highlight
couple of aspects that they believe are
worth mentioning first one is reading
the first part of the deserve Natalia
the preamble the vision and the
guideline and the guiding precedes one
is struck by the positive narrative on
migration while in the medium and the
positives migration is often subject to
criticism the GCM attest that migration
is and I quote a source of prosperity
innovation sustainable development and
circle and not at all a problem contrary
to the myths surrounding migration the
GCF converts that and he record again
majority of migrants around the world
travel work and live in safe and orderly
manner and the GCM defines three-phase
world words for successful migration
commonality
sharing and unity this are significant
words with positive political
connotation calling upon all of us to
work together in positive spirit to make
migration work for all second aspect is
analyzing the 23 objectives set out in
the GCF to make conclusions
roughly seven objectives are for
accreditation and contrary in countries
of origin fourteen objectives can be
considered as for countries of
destination among which eleven
objectives are also for transit country
this distribution makes sense as we
speak about immigrants we are talking
about person on the move leaving his or
her country either in transit country or
other destination 20 out of the 23
objectives are centered on migrants
themselves they aimed at protecting
migrants from watching their rights and
contain their access to services they
required this number refers to
personality of migrants in the Jews a
third dimension is looking at the
presentation and follow-up section we
find through innovation first one is a
new design of capacity building through
a state-of-the-art mechanism which will
open new opportunities with a new
approach for building capacities it's
based on three pillars one a connection
hub that facilitates demand drivin
Tibor made an integrated solution to
start upon for initial finessing to
realize project oriented solution 3 a
global knowledge platform as an online
open date source the similar element is
another machine and migration review
form with periodicities of four years
starting in 2022 it will be formed at
the global level through which monger
states can review the presentation
progress and guard the direction
the work of the United Nations it will
serve as a primary dr. Gruber muttered
global platform for member states to
discuss and share progress on the
permutation of all aspects a in our
coalition original character of
migration which is suffered for better
management of migration the Global Forum
will proceed by regional Aboriginal and
cross Regional Forum starting 2020 in
order to follow this important
development the secretary-general
decided to establish United Nation
Network on migration to ensure a 15th
and quadrant system wide support for a
presentation including the
capacity-building mechanism as well as
follow-up and revealed Global Compact in
response to the needs of member states
it is expected that our UI at the
National Organization on migration will
serve as the coordinated and Secretariat
of the network and that the network will
fully drove from the technical expertise
and experience of relevant entities
within United Nations system the work of
the network will be fully aligned with
existing coordination mechanism and
repositioning of the United Nations
Development system the network will
officially launch will be officially
launched on 9 December in Marrakesh
ladies and gentlemen what will happen in
Marrakesh next month the meeting the
Marrakesh next December is not intended
to be published and when they are events
to adopt did you say Morocco is offering
more than such a separating what Morocco
is proposing is a global event which
aspires to meet the expectation of the
migration community to this end Miroku
is proposed to hold the conference back
to back with the 11th summit of G
and global for migration and a look
which was killed in Marrakesh from 5 to
7 December 2018 bringing together
destroyers built up to the migration
week of Marrakesh in between some 60
side events will be organized during the
weekend of 8 9 December including the
fifth mayor's forum on mobility
migration and development first one in
Africa will coincide with the rushing of
G 7 JM debuggers mechanism and the Youth
Forum and some other 55 site events or
different aspects linked to migration
the programme of confidence will
comprise the following an opening
session with the formal adoption of GCM
I would like to reiterate that there
will be no signing of the dissent like
any other UN General Assembly document
it will be just adopted by governing by
the chair of the medication to plenary
meeting which will be running all day
long from 9 to 8 during the two days of
the covers this will be the space world
head of delegation will deliver their
main statement to the conference three
two dialogues which will be held in
parallel with the greenery the first
dialogue will focus on promoting action
on the commitment of GCL while the seven
will discuss partnership and innovative
initiative for the way forward as far as
participation is concerned I would like
to highlight the following level of
participation United Nations General
Assembly
lucien 72 2 2044 on the modalities of
their confidence and the lion that later
shall be helped at the highest level
possible including mental states and
government ladies and gentlemen the
following question that many of you my
us is what will happen after Marrakesh
first things immediately after Marrakesh
will be adoption by the General Assembly
in New York of the report of the
conference which will continue G said
this adoption is scheduled to around the
19th of December this will be the
opportunity for all this who have
comments or explanation to make on the
GCF and to conclude I would say that
adoption of G say by the end of this
year should not be seen as the end of
the this process at the contrary
Marrakesh will be the third step it will
mark the beginning of the real world at
all levels while then the imaginary
community should approved and the text
of this thing related won't have any
value if it's not followed up with
appropriate and concrete implementation
measures as such as the migration
community for hard to get to this stage
where finally the very first UN document
dealing with all aspects of regulation
will be adopted if work should be
doubled to make sure that the provision
of decision is translated and drawn with
adequate and concrete actions thank you
very much
thank you guys : Thank You Omar
presenting us it's a global document but
it is not a declaration is very concrete
steps in the global community are to
agree in varrock what what we would like
to wish inshallah well god help you with
that you did where is a good good job
and now I'm going to give the floor to a
person who is on the daily
were the United Nations when you entered
the United Nations building and see the
table of the events you will see Holy
See Holy See Holy See and particularly
when it is about the migration so let me
introduce you
his Excellency the Most Reverend birdie
to Azusa tittle our Bishop of soacha
apostle Ignacio permanent observer of
the Holy See to United Nations and the
permanent observer of the Holy See to
Organization of American States this is
the full title to a person we had behind
a huge carrier his portrait is severe
just in front of you and of course all
the colleagues here they are
representing their States and ambassador
is going well to share with you on his
head holiness on all holiness pope
francis vision on the global challenges
of migration thank you to be with us
today and you have it floor sir thank
you very much ambassador excellencies
ladies and gentlemen I'm pretty sure I'm
neither the first Catholic nor the first
member of the Catholic clergy to speak
at Yale an institution originally
founded by Puritans congregational crew
chief to form ministers to purify any
condition from whatever Vistage is of
Roman Catholic Church but still there I
would like to give a thank you very much
for this wonderful invitation which I
was very pleased to accept and I would
like also to express deep appreciation
of your interest the global challenge
that is migrations there was here four
colleagues from the there are four of us
here from the United Nations I would
like to focus my my talk on a kind of a
universal dimension of my question and
specifically of Pope Francis
vision and his idea on global migration
migration is as old as humanity itself
at the tone of the historical biblical
account we have Abraham who with his
family migrated from the ruler of the
Chaldeans
from what is now Iraq and settled in
Canada
what better biblical images of the
phenomenal migration can there be the
the mass migration of the house of
Israel to Egypt in flight from famine
and the reverse migration the exodus of
the Jewish people from Egypt back to
Canaan three Manship it themselves from
tyranny and slavery these round trip
migration so to speak already tells us
what are the primary drivers of
migration namely family reunification
with a whole family of Jacob joining
Joseph in Egypt poverty in want as a
result of the famine in Canaan the gross
violations of human rights leading to
violent conflicts with Easter lights
were reduced to slavery and hunted down
by the Egyptian forces and biblically
and literally speaking the longing for a
promised land the Bible especially the
Pentateuch are repeat with injunctions
to welcome strangers because as Moses
reminded them you yourselves were also
strangers in a foreign land
as the International worker the
inter-religious affairs for the American
Jewish Committee Rabbi David Rosen
descent judaism has an ancient history
as migrants that informs the jewish
teaching to help others in vulnerable
situations and all the other major
religious traditions and cultural
traditions have similar injunctions in
caring for strangers during the last
centuries before christ than the first
centuries ad the jews and definitions
the Greeks and the Romans were all over
the Mediterranean Basin in the early
Middle Ages the variants were not only
at the gates they settle down under wind
so the by
in power the new world was water for
movements of people's with Christopher
Columbus in Hispaniola 1492 with Vasco
da Gama rounding the Cape of Good Hope a
night in 1497 and Ferdinand Magellan
literally my backyard in the Philippines
in 1521 in fact he died just a couple of
miles from where I was born so we would
not have time to discuss the vices and
the virtues of the centuries of
colonization but I guess it suffice to
say that at this moment that these
historic landmarks assured in
transcontinental migrations fast
forwarding to the last three centuries
in the United States we had the English
Irish and Italians rapidly populated in
new york and the new and the new england
states the Nordics and the germans
Interpol's in the great lakes and the
Chinese and the Filipinos creeping into
the shores of California the India's and
Latinos feed large parts of it is not a
Southwest the Africans were fortunately
brought across the Atlantic to the
American South and young slaves these
voluntary and involuntary migrations
where did they study what has become the
prosperous and the beautiful music that
is the United States of America today
consider this data which His Excellency
has already mentioned in 2017 258
million people moved across
international borders that's just across
there Francis but that crosses
international borders a 50% increase in
17 years and the refugees from 60
million in credit into 26 million in
2017
more than 60% increase in just seven
years and around 70 million of those
68.5 are forced from their homelands
especially above all because of armed
conflicts they added to that around 40
million people
victims of human trafficking
now therefore it is very clear that
migration is a global challenge that
migration has have done the leading
factors in so many discussions in so
many policies that governments across
the world are making and I would just
like to see to say that migration has
also become one of the great pastoral
priorities of both Francis and one of
the priorities of the international
activity of the Holy See so just like to
ask a question probably what does the
Holy See well how does the Holy signal
see their migration and what approach
does the obviously recommend for the
sake of time I will respond rapidly to
these questions with regard to the Holy
See's understanding a migration I would
like to make three points first as I
tried to illustrate from Abraham to the
United Nations 2017 statistics and
migrants and refugees migration is not a
new phenomenon as I said migration is as
old as humanity itself while massive
numbers have recently been forced to
live their homes due to violent
conflicts persecution and grave
violations of human rights natural and
man-made disasters and the sports of
poverty migration is both a natural
response to crisis and a natural innate
desire of every human being for
happiness greater opportunities and a
better life second the Holy See believes
in both the right to migrate and the
prior right not to migrate voluntary
safe orderly regular and well-managed
migration contributes the development
and
enrichment during negotiations leading
to the 2016 New Year liberation for
refugees and migrants the Holy See
suggested a phrase that is now enshrined
in the Declaration it is an appeal to
the international community together to
create conditions that allow communities
and individuals to live in safety and
dignity in their own countries the Holy
See was also a principal contributor the
one is now paragraph 13 of the Global
Compact that his Excellency just
mentioned which states we must work
together to create conditions that allow
communities and individuals to live in
safety and dignity in their own
countries in order to achieve these
conditions the adverse drivers and
structural factors that can pen people
to leave their country of origin must be
minimized I was pleased to find in the
Global Compact a man prayer that the
Holy See practically always repeated
during all the negotiations and even
before the negotiations of the Global
Compact namely that migration should
never be an act of desperation third the
fundamental human rights of all migrants
regardless of their migration status
must be respected during the
negotiations in the Global Compact of
migration the Holy See requested an
explicit enumeration of services that
must be provided to migrants as flowing
from their fundamental human rights and
thus cannot be denied to them while
there was no consensus of this there is
nevertheless the explicit commitment to
ensure that all migrants regardless of
their migration status can exercise
their human rights through safe access
to basic services with regard to the
approach the Holy See recommends the
deal with a global phenomenon
raishin there is a phrase that we beat
to death the United Nations almost
returned namely that a global challenge
demands a global response there are
other phrases that we also be today say
that I'd say much has been done but much
still remains to be done that's always
true now the global phenomenon of
migration therefore requires a global
response in a phrase this means
shared responsibility while recognizing
and respecting the sovereign right of
individual states to make their
respective policies and regulation of
course according to their international
obligations and to international
humanitarian law the Holy See is a
strong believer and supporter of
regional and global frameworks to make
migration safe orderly regular and
voluntary thus from the very answer from
the very outset the Holy See was very
supportive of the whole process leading
to both the Global Compact for safe
orderly and regular migration the Global
Compact and refugees I would like to end
with what France when how Pope Francis
has summarized his vision on migration
and how to approach the global
challenges both Francis are summarized
in four verbs the overall approach of
the Catholic Church to the global
challenges of migration these four words
are to welcome to protect to promote and
to integrate to welcome this means to
offer migrants broader options to enter
destination countries safely and legally
and to assure that the repatriation
which is normally voluntary is carried
out under just and safe conditions
migrants must be guaranteed personal
the access the basic services regardless
of their status in all instances the
centrality of the human person obliges
us to treat every migrant with dignity
and respect that is Chewbacca the second
bird is to protect all necessary steps
must mistaken must be taken to defend
fundamental human rights and dignity of
migrants regardless of their migratory
status such protection begins in the
country of origin and consists in
offering reliable and verified
information before departure and in
providing safety from illegal recruiters
human smugglers and traffickers this
protection must continue as the migrant
moved through countries of transit and
arrived in countries of destination in
safeguarding the fundamental dignity of
every migrant we must try to find
alternative solutions solutions to
detention policy does not believe or
that's not see the attention of a
microchannel
as in the best and in the best interests
of the child as defined in the
convention of the rights of a child that
is to protect the third verb is to
promote going beyond the protection of
the rights and dignity of migrants
effective policies and programs should
be in place as much as possible to
ensure that migrants are enabled to
contribute to or earn their upkeep to
exercise their fundamental freedoms
improve their skills and better their
education participate in the social life
of their host communities and contribute
to the common good
fourth and lastly to integrate with
migration is well-managed a culture of
encounter is fostered migrants make a
positive
addition to the economy the social and
cultural life and to enriching
communities integration is not a
simulation that leads might better
suppress or to forget their own cultural
identity rather integration is a process
of mutual knowledge reciprocal openness
to what is good and positive from each
other's cultural identity we all know
integration is a huge challenge that in
many instances were failure to fit in
can lead to social exclusion and social
disharmony to minimize the negative
impacts of migration community level
initiatives and legislative measures are
both needed to achieve integration
ladies and gentlemen and I must so I
would like to end by emphasizing and
recommending what this excellency has
already Illustrated to us the Global
Compact for safe orderly in regular
migration only believes there is an
historic advance in our shared
responsibility to act especially those
who find themselves in very difficult
and precarious situations the Global
Compact will serve as international
reference reference point for best
practices and international cooperation
in the global management of migration
the compact will be successful it
becomes a guide an effective guide of a
shared journey of solidarity and
largeness of spirit of respect and
responsibility towards migrants this
journey can only happen if all of us
will make our own contribution thank you
very much
Thank You excellency thank you indeed
and thank you for bringing us to the
golden rule or rule of your atrocity do
to others what you want them to do to
you and don't do what
do not want to do to you so all the
religions are seeing on the protection
of the other strangers of the migrants
even we can find it in the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights everyone has
a right to freedom to of moment and
resign residence within the borders of
each state everyone has right to seek
and enjoy in other countries Iceland
from persecution everyone has the right
to a nationality so all the religions
the international documents Universal
documents are saying about that but on
the ground they have different pictures
we have today two colleagues who are
representing the different regions East
Asia Europe where the situation is not
so easy as we would like to have and so
I would like them to share with us their
vision how to implement the ideas
universal ideas into the practice and I
would like to invite you to take a floor
a representative your country which is
generously hosting the huge amount of
the refugees as to the United Nations
calculations around nine hundred twenty
nine thousand Rohini refugees sheltering
in Bangladesh and hey today we have a
privilege to have today at this table
his Excellency ambassador must have been
moment permit represent of Bangladesh to
the United Nations the personality has a
huge huge experience in the
international organizations he knows
exactly what does it mean food crisis
serving in the food organization world
food programs so you may find all these
details on on the screen but what is
going on his country this is something
which is amazing we are to applaud
applaud them what they are doing and
what the international community could
contribute to to help to help these
in a crisis and other crises is this
what we are waiting well to to hear from
your address ambassador you have floor
thank you
better diary for inviting me and for the
introduction indeed it's a pleasure for
me for being invited here by the Yale
Macmillan Center we have already heard
from ambassador Hill Olli the host of
the DCM next month and also how the
background of this GCM and also from the
pub the representative from the Holy See
in fact Holy See has been very much
involved throughout the negotiations and
upholding the win-win narrative of
migration or the positive story of
migration so that's why we express my
gratitude to the Holy See and its
participation before coming to the
specific question of the Rohingyas I
just had a few points on the GCM and if
permitted by mr. Hillel II to offer my
you know small critic of what we have so
far and you know what we we can aspire
to have now regarding the migration
whether it is a global challenge or not
we believe that the despite many real
challenges there is ample evidence that
migration is beneficial for both the
migrants and the host communities in in
economic and social terms and the basic
challenge before us how to maximize the
benefits of migration rather than
remaining obsessed about minimizing the
so-called risks nowadays all the
countries or many most of the countries
are at the same time countries of origin
transit destination as well as return
now Bangladesh is a major migrate
sending country are used to be and we
have almost about 10 million expatriates
and the Diaspora community abroad
and we have a whole area of migrants
across the globe from low-skilled to
blue-collar as well as you know
professionals remittance has robust role
in transcending our national growth and
investment on the other hand as
mentioned we also are having the
experience as a receiving country and
since 25th of August 2017 last year we
have received more than 700,000 raw
Inga's who were forcibly displaced from
the northern rock Hinde province of
myanmar and before that another 86,000
and before that a few hundred more
thousand so all together right now
bangladesh is hosting more than a
million or you know close to 1.1 million
of these people and the government
recognizes the human face of these grave
crisis and opened its borders for saving
lives and continued to support the
distressed raw Inga's with its limited
resources to meet up their basic needs
to attain a peaceful solution Bangladesh
government has been exercising both
bilateral and multilateral channels and
the safe and the dignified return of
their Hingis to their homeland is our
priority and just to share with the
audience here tomorrow we are going to
sort of consider the resolution this
year's resolution in the third committee
on the situation on Myanmar and where it
is expected to be voted upon like last
year last year this resolution was
adopted to the vote of 135 in favour 10
against and 26 abstentions
last year's resolution was co-sponsored
by the Organization of Islamic
Cooperation however this year given the
gravity of the situation and also the
increased or heightened level of
awareness we have both the European
Union as well as YC as the co-sponsors
and as of today we have 101
co-sponsors for this resolution so this
resolution is actually all about having
some sort of accountability for the
atrocities that were allegedly committed
against the Inga's so without such
accountabilities in place we feel it is
very difficult to to convince or
persuade the ruinous to return to their
homeland tomorrow also happens to be
another important day where the actual
repatriation is supposed to begin
between the two countries but we are
sort of facing a very tough choice or
decision or hit a kind of a crossroad
where we are finding it very difficult
for the for our people to find lingas
who would be willing to go back unless
there is a conducive sort of environment
or atmosphere inside the Rakhine
province so we need this as you said
that what the international community
can do so I believe that the
international community the academia and
civil society they can you know all
support these kind of actions in the
General Assembly or sometimes in the
Security Council or the Human Rights
Council
so that Myanmar will be persuaded to do
more both in terms of improving the
ground situation or having a better
conducive environment for the return as
well as to have some kind of
accountability credible accountability
mechanism in place so that these people
have more confidence to go back so this
is where things stand right now we think
that migration is not a problem but a
solution for many development challenges
as in the 2030 for sustainable
development has labeled migration as one
of the major enablers for development
and portrayed migrants as the agent of
change it recognizes the important role
of migration in reducing inequality
within and between states as well as its
effectiveness as a tool for addressing
and social disparities in attaining
gender equality to optimize its full
benefits migration needs to be safe
orderly regular and responsible as
stated in SDG 10.7 now how we can make
this happen if you you know points--
come to my mind I will not elaborate
here for the brevity of time just
mentioned for example we must strengthen
in the rule of law at all levels and
migrants should to field an obligation
to avail legal and regular channels of
migration and move between countries in
an orderly fashion security and public
confidence matters States and the
citizens of the Republic have legitimate
reasons to demand secure borders and the
capacity determine who enters and stays
in their territories but the
counterproductive and discriminatory
policies for restricting migration often
corrodes the high values of a welfare
state and leaves migrants in a security
centric sort of dilemma as far as the
host countries are concerned as already
mentioned it has to be a shared
responsibility to ensure the governance
or the movement of the people it cannot
be the sole responsibility of a single
country or a single you know host
community then migration should not be
undertaken as an act of desperation
already mentioned by the distinguished
Holy See representative it should be a
choice restrictive or ineffectual labor
policies laws and employment customs
often create major obstacles in
optimizing the economic and social
potentials of the migrant workers so the
labor laws if they are poorly governed
and also if the decent work
circumstances are not created then it
will also have a problem migrant workers
of all types are often excluded from
even basic coverage by social protection
instruments and schemes in some of the
host countries so this is another issue
another disturbing trend is the
utilization of detention as a deterrent
measure to stop irregular migration so
we try to address this also in the
migration debate at the Union UN I think
ambassador Hill early very eloquently
covered that starting from the New York
declaration and you know the lack of you
know documents and rules and you know
conventions in this regard and now this
Global Compact for safe orderly and
regular migration is a kind of a
watershed development in this UN
discourse now what we expect from the
Global Compact here I'll offer some
critics as one of the promoters of this
concept Bangladesh wanted a more
ambitious an aspirational compact that
is more legally binding in nature we
place the commitments of New York
declaration as a baseline and aimed at
further advancement in all its aspects
in this compact we feel we could have
done more for the migrants with some
more flexibility would have dropped the
reference to non legally binding compact
push the reference to the International
Convention on the protection of the
rights of all migrant workers and
members of their families which by the
way only 51 ratifying countries and most
of the developed countries are out of it
to the body of the text from the
footnote which appears only in the
footnote at the current current format
we could have included a saving clause
and have commitments for ending child
detentions which we failed some other
important issues also remain unresolved
which however should not block our
ambitions to do more for the migrants in
future because we like to believe
ambassador Hill early hinted this they
know what next that this global compact
is a living document and this is just
the beginning which he also mentioned
the Global Compact will be judged not by
its substance by its ability to bring
positive changes on the ground at this
point I would also like to mention many
of you from academia perhaps you will
also appreciate this that the possible
impact of the fourth Industrial
Revolution
which is marked by the advent of
artificial intelligence
3d printing robotics driverless cars
etcetera this technology is already
there it is a matter of time for artists
artificial intelligence to change our
business models when it will happen the
traditional way of looking into
migration will have to be changed there
will be less importance on skill
training or skill matching in the
traditional sense as well as obtaining
new skills through human migration
mechanical hands will replace those of
human in job sectors the market economy
will not follow the model of its
business as usual the supply-demand
model needs to be reshaped and the
developing countries like Bangladesh
will face enormous challenges as the
dividend of having a large pool of human
resources may not benefit the economy in
the same way as it is envisaged today
only a living global compact could
address these uncertain dynamics in the
market and act accordingly shape the
policy landscape for global human
mobility it has not been really
addressed but I think we need to take a
very serious look at it the other issue
is the global community needs to think
more on the climate change and migration
continuum the topic is well placed in
the global compact but the broader
perspective is missing sometimes the
demarcation line between a refugee and
the climate displaced person is very
very fine
both needs special treatment and
international protection particular
focus needs to be placed on addressing
intern internal displacement due to
climate change as well as on the
capacity building of neighboring states
as they are the first responders in case
of climate displacement as a climate
vulnerable country Bangladesh fully
realized the importance of adoption of
my mitigation and rehabilitation in
dealing with this continuum more
research and credible data are essential
to approach this issue holistically
sometimes from a narrow political
standpoint we tend to make a binary
division between regular and irregular
migrants yet regular migrants range from
individuals on short term work or
student visas to power
residents of foreign countries and those
who acquire a new citizenship likewise
there is a spectrum of irregular
migration from overstaying a visa to
deliberately deliberately forced to
undermine the border controls so this is
another issue where we need to focus few
member states have announced their
decision of withdrawing themselves from
the compact this happens at a time when
the xenophobic political narratives
about migration are all too widespread
we need to understand that migration
related challenges could only be better
dealt with thorough thoroughly
dispelling alarmist misperceptions of
these effects political leaders have to
take responsibility for reframing
national discourses on the issue as well
as for policy reforms through
mainstreaming migration in national
development strategies realistic policy
debates supported their better data on
migration should encourage at national
level besides governments civil society
academia and business need to play a
bigger role in changing these
perceptions and make lives better for
the migrants so I think I have covered
quite a bit and maybe during the
question and answer session we can
discuss more thank you
thank you indeed thank you well I am
sharing your concerns I would like that
diplomacy would be not the art of
possible but the art of impossible thank
you for mentioning the climate change
migrants that is true that all refugees
are migrants but not all migrants are
refugees in terms of the legal
recognition so we are waiting of course
from more of a summit well to have a
first step and then we will encourage
the next steps well to bring more legacy
in understanding the phenomena of
migration and to bring all the migrants
at least in the same legal field and
last but not least my good friend a
neighbor ambassador McHale leader
well he's from academia well the exact
exact partner and he understands why
they are here we need to well to to
combine theory and practice sometimes a
theory is not in the practice and what
is in the practice should be in the
theory the region of the central Europe
master is represented is the region of
our integrities Ukraine who is also the
contributing the migrants and enlarging
the challenges to the to the region of
Europe
well so and I like him well to share
with us on his country view from the
original respect it was probably brought
up all the ambassadors here they are
representing their own States if they
want to broaden their own stage thank
you thank you very much yeah ambassador
for for this introduction and for the
invitation as you have mentioned I feel
at home in the academic setting so it's
always a pleasure to to come and to
contribute I of course I have been put
into a difficult situation of being the
last speaker at the moment when so many
good things have already been said and
maybe I'm the last obstacle between the
introductory remarks and and in the
discussion and usually it is the
discussion which is the most important
component of meetings like that and and
this is where we can exercise the some
of the real questions so really looking
forward to that but allow me to to share
with you a few points from my
perspective and of course a little bit
also from from the European perspective
excellencies dear colleagues
professors dear friends ladies and
gentlemen it has been mentioned several
times today already that migration is a
reality but at the same time it is a hot
topic a sensitive issue in many places
and for many reasons including in the
media including in parliamentary or
other political discussions in this
course but we have already mentioned
here several times today that over the
past year the issue of migration has
been high on the agenda of the United
Nations and in particular of the General
Assembly and I think it is really
important to emphasize him and probably
it cannot be overemphasized the the
great deal of work that has been done in
recent 18 months on this particular
topic and you know this is really the
the important cornerstone that that we
should continue building upon despite
the challenges so an event like that and
a discussion like that is certainly a
welcome opportunity as well as my
colleagues have already mentioned people
people have always moved for various
reasons for education for family for
employment and careers or in other words
for better life and we we should take in
that context migration as a natural
thing despite what some media including
some European media recently portrayed
most migration takes place within
regions for example the highest portion
of international migration takes place
between developing countries between
developing countries not between
developing and developed world and it is
about the 35% of migration that acts
happens between developing countries or
if you will within within the South
another interesting fact may be that
migrants in 2017 contributed about 9.5
percent to global GDP even even though
they only account for about 3.4 percent
of global population so there is a
discrepancy and actually a discrepancy
in in in in the favor of migrants and
while almost six hundred billion US
dollars in remittances were sent abroad
in 2017 eighty-five percent of the
migrants income remain in their host
countries often contributing to local
economies so there is also you know the
economic optics which we can which we
can take and let me stop here briefly
and actually say that even for my own
country for Slovakia which as we
sometimes like to say lies in the heart
of Europe because if you ever look for
the geographical center of Europe you
will find it you will find it in a
Catholic Church or right next to the
Catholic Church in Chemnitz cabaña in
central Slovakia
so of course you may have different
theories you will find different
theories of where the geographical
center is but we are proud to call
ourselves the heart of Europe and as the
heart of Europe we probably have a
responsibility that that comes with that
Slovakia is a country of about 5.5
million people and currently I can say
that about 65,000 Slovaks live in the
United Kingdom and this is a very recent
phenomenon since 2004 when Slovakia
joined the European Union well we are
facing some other issues in that
particular country in the United Kingdom
which is busy with with the brexit
situation and the brakes of discussions
but nevertheless it is it is a clear and
strong indication of the
meaningful nature of and the reality of
migration in economic terms in social
terms and in other terms it may be
interesting from the United States point
of view that about 800,000 people in the
United States claim Slavic origin so for
a country of 5.5 million people having
not necessarily at the aspera but people
who actually know that their ancestors
came from that part of Europe even
though it may have not been called
Slovakia at that particular time that we
have such such an interesting number of
people and just to contribute also with
the fact that about 500,000 Slovaks half
a million moved to the United States
between 1880 and the mid 1920s so I
think it speaks for itself and it is not
at some point Bratislava which is the
capital of Slovakia that that was the
largest Slovak city for various reasons
one of them of course being that that it
is a very it has always been a very
multicultural multilingual and
cosmopolitan city and it is a city where
German Hungarian and Slovak have always
been spoken so it was not brightest lava
but there were two other cities
Cleveland Ohio and Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania that had a that had a
greater Slovak population then the the
current capital of Slovakia and then you
would find a lot of Slovaks in in the
states of Illinois in New Jersey New
York to just name a few or in Trenton
Connecticut which is not too far from
from where we are right now you would
find the only the only non territorial
Sinnott of the American Lutheran Church
we have the Slovak science in it which
has the headquarters in Trenton
Connecticut and we have we are proud of
that particular element as well so just
to demonstrate a few points from from
the practical practical perspective of
my own country well briefly on some of
the challenges that that we are we are
facing because obviously I do not want
to paint a an idealistic picture or a
situation where we do not see we are
blindfolded we do not see the the
challenges challenges of course include
large and uncontrolled movement
movements plays they strain on countries
and cities there can be brain drains or
surfaces of labor countries of all kinds
can face security risks and demographic
change also migrants themselves may face
vulnerability we have seen more than
26,000 migrant deaths in 2006 2014
thousands are thousands more are trapped
in a cycle of exploitation at the hands
of smugglers and traffickers and 48% of
migrants are women they often face
violence and exploitation so a number of
challenges and the GCM the Global
Compact is exactly our way of addressing
this particular global phenomena
phenomenon and our way of trying to
address the situation through a global
solution for for a global problem and I
really believe that this is a
comprehensive response that we
being able to take and the conference in
Marrakesh in December will will really
play a significant role in in on the way
of finalizing our work on the Global
Compact as has been mentioned it is not
a legally binding document and does not
create obligations but it is a useful
tool that we can rely on in in terms of
addressing the challenges the Global
Compact is based not on theory but on
what is actually happening on the ground
the drivers of migration have already
been mentioned but these are the
so-called push factors that we of course
are addressing you know through the
Global Compact whether it is the issue
of discrimination and social inclusion
or meeting labor demands or the question
of how to prevent migrants from falling
into smuggling rings and risking the
people risking people's lives and
children many unaccompanied others
abandoned so these are the the obvious
challenges our answer that we have all
presented to you this afternoon to the
challenges is engaging through
multilateralism it has really been a
test case for the UN and for
multilateralism and I believe so far we
have been able to really give the best
possible answer through the multilateral
framework addressing the complex
sensitive and pressing global concern
and we have been able to do it together
through consultations through
negotiations and of course the the work
is not finished yet
conference in Marrakech it's not the end
to the process on the contrary it is
just a beginning because as ambassador
Hill Allah and others have mentioned
there is there is a lot more that would
be following and the the tool that we
have at our disposal is there to help us
it is in no way intended to be
prescriptive or to endanger country's
sovereignty or anything like that on the
contrary it offers a cooperation
framework that we have at our disposal
actually we can draw some parallel with
the 2030 agenda during those
negotiations also many thought it was
undoable but today we have the SDGs they
are also non-binding but they have been
a major step forward in in terms of
galvanizing the necessary work that we
need to do in the in the development
context and migration actually is in all
three pillars of the UN work whether it
is peace and security social and
economic development or human rights it
is important to know that migration can
be well managed and that it can
therefore become a better better agent
for development as well as the g10 in
particular has already been mentioned
development can help to encounter push
factors it can ensure that people move
not out of necessity but by choice the
Global Compact of course we don't see as
a magic pill or as a magic formula but
it is the first ever of its kind and we
can use it in many great strides but as
I have mentioned we have a lot of work
ahead of us because to really make an
impact the text the compact must come to
life to truly benefit countries but most
importantly to benefit the people so I
would stop
at that for my introductory remarks and
very happy of course to engage in for
the discussion Thank You Miguel thank
you to be to be the last but not the
least good good finish and now I'm
addressing the audience we have some I
think twenty thirty five men it's a bit
behind the schedule well but so we still
have time for question answers please be
assured I have a question for
representative from Morocco your
excellency
where is Morocco stand in relation to
development of the Western Sahara and
the possibility of settling refugees
there as a way to deal with sorry two
problems at once perhaps convincing
Europe past particularly the French to
invest in the region as the Moroccan
Spanish border becomes the next gateway
for refugees attempting to enter Europe
thank you very much for your question
it's not the issue of our roundtable but
as I believe in freedom of expression I
will tell you that the Salah is Moroccan
and there is political process political
process that we lead for political
solution and just the last resolution of
security cancer 24 40s calling for
political solution pragmatic realistic
and based on compromise so Morocco is
working with the personally why of the
secretary-general mr. president former
President Germany
Horst köhler we will meet next month
inshallah and problem is we need Algeria
to be around the table because our julia
is the country that is hosting for Azari
is financing for israel is army for
Rosario
is
containing diplomatic rapport for
Rosario so without their presence around
the table we cannot move forward so
let's hope that now that mutation have
been sent to our area as part as the
first concern party we hope that by next
month
inshallah we might pave the way for real
negotiations and pragmatic and realistic
and political solution
thank you Mark well my question is
around climate change and climate chaos
and extreme weather and the ideas of
safe orderly and regular migration as
climate chaos kicks in more and more
preclude people from being able to make
safe regular and orderly transitions as
their homes are flooded and incinerated
any any of the panels to speak to that
already mentioned or flag this issue I
mean just take the case of Bangladesh we
have a landmass of fifty five thousand
square miles and which is the state of
Wisconsin here and you pack 160 million
people there and with you know global
warming of we don't maybe a couple of
degree centigrades in the next 20-30
years
one third of Bangladesh is you know
feared to be under water and already we
are seeing some trends of salinity and
corrosion and other things so therefore
almost like 30 million people would be
threatened to leave their lands or the
you know homes for better or higher
ground now we are doing whatever is
possible
on the adaptation sort of front
mitigation of course we can change very
little with our own carbon footprint
already very low therefore without
international cooperation without
understanding of this problem
Bangladesh alone can never solve a
problem of this magnitude if we are
talking about very small island
developing states with 10,000 15,000
20,000 population maybe you know other
countries can come to rescue this
population and maybe save them but no
one is going to take 30 million people
even our neighbors will not be
enthusiastic so this is a major problem
we don't have any solution in our hand
except to you know slowly adapt to this
situation but then if the global warming
is actually rising as the way they are
rising last year being the hottest year
in the planet the trends are really as
you mentioned chaotic and these chaos
cannot be tackled or solved by single
countries we need understanding and
global cooperation but I don't have any
answer just just yet couple wars mmm
when I was ambassador three years ago
for nine years you have been pushing
through the Security Council to
recognize to recognize the the problem
of the Pacific Islands mostly that
climate change is existential for them
because they are diving and the first
answer to your question is the climate
migrants should be recognized as
refugees because refugees all of races
are migrants but not all migrants are
refugees refugees are more or less
protected legally but migrants not and
so to bring the global community to
understanding that for climate change
migrants
this is existential issue that carry bar
to wallow Vanuatu in Pacific and not
only in Pacific well there is
viewing so for them this is a security
issue
that's why legal problem should be
resolved and well well I think it was
probably what has become the most famous
and the most read document of Pope
Francis is loaded to see on the care for
our common home the planet and certainly
it has it is a constant preoccupation
and I believe there has been some
progress
and when it comes to treating dealing
with a question of climate change at the
international level first of all we have
the we have the Paris Accord of 2015 and
in less than in three weeks we have we
have the cop 24 I mean the 24th
conference of States party to the United
Nations Framework Convention and climate
change and there will be certainly a big
recognition on the fact that while it is
difficult for many countries to transfer
might see true to change from fossil
fuels to renewable energy
thankfully the highlights of the meeting
will be that there will be a transition
I mean everybody should work towards a
transition from what it pollutes what
brings climate change into renewable
energy clean energy in the global car
park itself the question of recognizing
not only sudden but also slow onset of
natural catastrophes provoked by climate
change came towards the end of the
negotiations there was much debate
whether it should be included or not in
the end it is included but not as a
separate objective at this part of an of
an objective now the question of whether
or not they should be recognized
refugees as victims of or they call what
we call how climate change migrants the
term is not in the global compact yet
but certainly it is a very good point of
debate whether or not they should be
recognized as refugees because there are
other considerations like you know if
you are a victim of unsaid
natural catastrophe lead to climate
change in a country then you could be
transferred to another part of the
country etc etc but there are indeed
cases in which climate change has
provoked tremendous migration and
displacement of people's probably the
biggest example now is to just the
advance in this certification is in the
South Sara thank you thank you so much
for being here
um yeah on this issue of refugees so you
spoke most directly to the Global
Compact on migration but unit share also
facilitated the development of the
Global Compact on refugees which is
expected for adoption later this year as
well and I wondered if you saw these two
compacts as just parallel instruments
both non legally binding or if they were
supposed to complement each other in any
specific ways so just curious for your
thoughts on how these two instruments
are working together thank you very much
for your question very pertinent one I
would like to recall that when we start
discussion after the summit on migration
three years almost three years ago the
objective was to have one document
dealing with refugees and migration but
thanks to the would not save the fights
but the deformity and the combination of
effort by Bangladesh Mexico Morocco
Philippine we pushed to have two
documents and to have two tracks and our
Russian was very clear for Refugees
there is already enough international
law we have conventions and you have the
right
the imperative profession protecting
refugees in all the international
components and at the national treaty
but the other side refugees we have only
one
I mean migration we have only one
workers and their families and even this
document is not Universal because there
is only I think 45 51 51 countries so
that's why we push to have and who make
pressure to have one document dealing
with migration fortunately we managed to
have them separately the the Global
Compact only produced just enforced and
reaffirmed apprenticeship
on Convention refugees convention on
pivot and 1951 and it's protocol of 67
and others as women but for the compact
that's the first one on migration the
first UN document its historical it's
just the beginning it's not enough it's
not an exemplary document I understand
the frustration of my brother the
ambassador of Bangladesh we all would
like to have binding documents to have
more rights protecting rights to the
mainland but unfortunately we need to
have consensual documents a document
that will be agreed by all countries we
don't want to have documents only for
country of origin or documents only for
Africa or for a CEO or a country of
transit we want to have document that is
dealing with the rights of migrants
everywhere in their country of origin
transit and destination and also to have
the old countries on board to protect
the migrants of course I agree that
varies for us various difference for
some countries there is difference
between legal and illegal migrants but
for us it's human being
it's woman with children this man is old
people they have to be protected by
should not be put in in jail children
have to get all their rights protected
education health and this need to have
common language and when we have a
consensual document it means and in
definition consensus it means that is a
sum of goodwill of acceptation that's
why we have this document is not it's
not very weak it's comprehensive one
what is just the beginning and does it
have been said already as an operative
and alive document we hope that in the
process of reviewing the this document
in the coming years we will manage to
improve it but at least here we have a
very strong very historical and very
guiding document where cooperation will
be the base and protecting the values
and human rights of all migrants all
around the world
is dead hi Maya PEO School of Medicine
to prime minister kaya tree so about a
month ago we had an event a two-day
event looking at climate induced
displacement and we gathered a variety
of experts around science understanding
migration and legal experts and we spend
a lot of time trying to understand how
do you think about attribution how how
do you ascertain the causes of migration
which are always multifactorial even for
catastrophic events even for slow-moving
events and because legal frameworks
require some understanding of
attribution in order to think about
rights and responsibilities you fall
into this convention because this is why
you've moved as opposed to falling under
the Refugee Convention because
persecution is the basis the primary
basis for your movement and actually the
two-day discussion made me think about
the complexities of attribution which
made me think whether we need to move
away from it entirely away from the
legal based framework and move more to
out-of-the-box creative solutions and
economic solutions and extra economic
reparations for math populations that
will be moving and I take the point
about consensual 'ti I take the
important about moving the community but
I don't know that we have
time and I really wonder if we ought to
be moving away from the ideal legal
framework and more - we need a mass
global fund dealing with migration and
moving populations and saving money for
that because we will be seeing that
we've already seen this year's UNF
Triple C report things are moving much
faster than we expected
yes so the answer is in the question
well any any comments from from the
table yeah well I think the question
about revision or there has been much
already talked about what they called
climate change justice so it is very far
from you know obtaining international
consensus which means that you know poor
countries are very as his Excellency
said very have very very very small
carbon footprint because especially
across centuries and decades and
centuries even they they were not they
were not they are not they were not they
have not been industrial countries so
their carbon footprint is very slow and
yet the way the effects of climate
change are being suffered mostly by them
for many reasons geographical and also
for reasons that we have no capacity for
very small capacity of mitigation and
adaptation these are related to main we
might say a solutions to to climate
change so that's a the question of of
climate change justice will will not go
away but then fertile a I would say it's
still very very far from being
considered it was a big question during
the Paris Accord negotiations which
lasted two full weeks but it did not get
some traction especially the the wealthy
countries the industrial countries who
certainly have much bigger footprints
gas house mean greenhouse footprints a
carbon footprints across at least the
Industrial Revolution time where we
would not accept that but there was the
an increase a little bit of an increase
in the final
moments of the negotiations what we
called a global fund a common fund for
climate for mitigation and adaptation
measures so that is that was a kind of a
compromise but still very small as
compared to what many of the different
countries really demanded thank you I
just like to add that you know of course
attribution is a very tricky and legally
complicated issue but then I believe
that if we have a political consensus
and kind of political will then it is
possible to sort of you know find a
cause and effect and and we can have
carbon taxes and fund and then use that
for a compensation or resettlement of
people who are directly affected by sea
level rise in terms of losing their land
so theoretically it is possible but of
course we need a political will if we
deny the very existence of climate
change then of course we are going in
the opposite direction thank you let me
just add if I may briefly we have
mentioned several times that that the
this is the first step this is the
beginning this is by no means the end of
the process and there have been other
things already done you you probably
know that also the International
Organization for Migration which has its
headquarters in in Geneva has now been
made part of the UN system for for
obvious reasons we need to strengthen
the the frameworks we need to strengthen
the way we we are able to address the
situations on the ground of course
situation on the ground is often
complicated nobody can always have a
clear distinction between you know which
situation is
refugee and where it ends and where
where there is a migrant because things
are of course more complex and more
difficult but it it was felt that it is
important to have this framework both
for you know both for Refugees which
already is better covered as colleagues
have mentioned but also for for migrants
and it is a set of recommendations where
where member states can can decide which
one best fits according to the according
to the practical needs and and the
practical situations of course we need
to address also the financing frameworks
and we in the European context have been
discussing this is a lot of working a
lot on on strengthening also the the
mechanisms of financing trust funds have
been set up which directly also address
the the issue of migration but the the
the approaches need to be comprehensive
needs to be multi fault and we are
certainly committed to to continuing
with with with these efforts thank you
so to be the last question
my question is to ambassadors mcgf and
mermen how do you feel about how do you
view the role of regional powers like
China India and Russia in resolving
their hunger crisis thank you very much
of course we depend a lot on on the role
of the neighboring countries who have a
better understanding of the situation in
that context China India and instead of
Russia maybe Japan would be more
relevant and they all have a role and I
think they are helping Myanmar at the
moment to build infrastructure for the
returnees would be returnees and as the
secretary says that it's not only the
physical infrastructure but we have
to also build bridges amongst different
communities so that they feel safe you
know in a better atmosphere so we have
to also invest in the mental sort of
infrastructure of that area in the
society and in that context these
countries can also you know help Myanmar
to to have a better conducive
environment so that these people their
owners can actually return in safety
dignity and in sustainability so they
have a huge role but if that role is is
mixed up with a political geopolitical
or economic interest then we end up in a
very a sort of complex and protracted
situation so we are working very closely
with these countries so that we can
actually solve this you know protracted
issue think few words to add China and
in Russia they're permanent members of
the Security Council and their voice
could and should be most stronger there
thank you well let me on behalf to thank
our panelists for being with us today
for sharing with us on the very
complicated issue of course the global
community is looking the ways how to
protect the migrants legally how to
protect them operationally because the
biggest gap today the lack of the legacy
the lack of the operation allottee well
how to bring the help in time what to do
with the those who are diving in the
Pacific Indian and Caribbean what to do
with them
there is no way to to protect them from
the UN climate changes how to adapt them
if there is no way how to adopt this
only way to help them to move out who
will cost them what the legal framework
of this hosting
temporary permanently whatever
nationality so
let me know we have two to wish the the
summit in Morocco be successful in LA to
to thank all the participants today and
the dear welcome back for the next
seminars which will be the next semester
only so within the series of global
governments
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]